LARRY SUSSKIND: We are
excited, and honored,
to have Professor Stephen
Carpenter with us.
And this is the first
of a series of events.
I'm Larry Susskind.
I'm on the faculty in
Urban Studies and Planning.
It's interesting to me
that several people here
have a water interest.
Several people here have
a planning interest.
artistic, or art methods
interests.
Several people here have
public education interest.
And all of those
are alive and well
in the Department of
Urban Studies and Planning
in different kinds of ways.
There is an environmental
group in the department
that I have had some
responsibility for.
And water is a concern within
the environmental group.
Not just domestically,
but internationally,
which relates to
part of your work.
We're interested in water as an
environmental justice concern,
not just a natural resource
management concern.
And so, when I first
learned of some
of the ways in which
your work has focused
on making clean water available
to people in different places,
there was a direct connection
with that aspect of what we do.
I was really interested
in how issues of race
could be raised in a way that
conversation was possible.
And that is another
very big part
of what our department, and
our school, are interested in.
So by way of
background, those are
some of the thematic interests
that led us to very much want
you to be here.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Well thanks, Larry.
As far back as I can
remember, I like making stuff.
I would just make
things, you know?
I'm the oldest of four boys.
And the oldest and
the youngest were
born 5 and 1/2 years apart.
No twins.
So we were constantly
together and doing things,
and we would make things.
Like a set of golf clubs.
My dad had golf clubs.
We weren't allowed to use
them, so we made them.
Of course we used his
copper pipe for the plumbing
in the house.
So making things was always part
of what I did, and have done,
and just engaging in the--
it shifts, and it has moved.
My background's really
pottery-- is really ceramics.
Touching the clay, touching
the mud, making things.
That's my degree, is in
ceramics and fine art.
I don't know what it was,
this urge, ability, interest
for teaching, for education.
So that complicated
the situation.
Making stuff, and
teaching stuff-- well,
actually, you can do that.
That's called being an art
educator, or a teacher.
And the ceramics
piece stayed with.
I couldn't shake the clay,
I couldn't get the clay out
of my fingernails.
The making of things
had to always be there.
And then I taught
elementary school art,
I was the art teacher,
elementary school.
And that was among the most
invigorating experiences
of my life, because
the students are always
about making something.
Their bodies are always moving.
They're constantly in a state
of absorbing what they're
doing in the world, and seeing
other people doing, and moving,
and checking, and--
so that energy was
quite interesting to me.
Followed that experience
up with a doctoral degree
in art education.
But the idea was that the
making, and the teaching,
and the learning, and the asking
of questions through art--
through the visual imagery
that you're talking about--
that was what was so important.
And you mentioned
the notion of access.
Well, we didn't have golf clubs.
We didn't have access to--
we saw them, but we didn't
have access to them.
So making our own access, I'm
interested in that as well.
How does one make
one's own access?
So moving around to a series
of different universities
as an art educator.
Part of both
graduate degrees was
about being in the clay
studio as much as it
was being in the seminar room.
That was really the
focus of my dissertation.
In the clay studio we were
talking, and critiquing,
about color, and shape, and
form, and how the glaze works.
And on the other side of
the same part of campus--
on the other side of the road--
in the theory classes
in art education,
we're talking about postmodern
theory, and feminist theory,
and film theory, and
interpreting installations,
and performances.
And then on the other
side of the road,
I'd go to my class the next day.
We were, again, critiquing.
But we were talking about,
oh, I like that handle.
Show me how you made the handle.
This handle works
and that one doesn't.
We never defined
what works meant.
But putting those together-- the
making, and the interpreting,
and thinking, and
theorizing in both registers
doesn't have to be separated.
So to think of us, even with
labels, I find kind of curious.
We have to find a
place on campus,
but to understand
that we can move
in and out of those spaces.
And we can start to
shed those identities.
The kind of group that
has self assembled today
speaks to multiple
interests that I have,
and trying to weave it into,
what is an art education?
How does one learn through
the making of things,
through the display
of cultural products
through cultural production?
What kind of questions
can we ask, not just
about what someone
else has made,
but what kind of
questions can we
ask through the act
of making, itself?
We can make meaning
through relationships,
we can make meaning
through conversation,
we can make meaning through
verbal or written responses.
So it's the making of meaning,
making of cultural product,
making of a difference.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Right.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: So
this notion of making
doesn't have to always have
this physicality to it.
I'm saying all that
to say, the clay
left my fingernails for a
while, until I moved to Texas.
My wife is an engineer--
a mechanical engineer,
material science--
and it's a great opportunity
for her to move there.
For me, there's no art
education there at all.
They got my CV and didn't
know where to put me.
Sent it all over campus.
And finally, the education
folks said, oh, we'll take him.
It has education in his
degree, we'll take him.
Telling you all that
to say, I got to Texas,
and art education had to be--
I had reinvent
it, or at least, I
had to figure out
what I meant by it.
And how I fit in.
If you don't have
an art department,
how do you have art education?
Well, you just open a
studio in your garage
and have people over on Fridays.
I did that.
Or you can engage in the
work in the curriculum,
that fixed set of notions
and premeditated concepts,
terms, practices,
skills, construct
that educational experience.
My entrance into a more
curriculum instruction space
was through my background as an
artist, and as an art educator.
The water filter work that I
do, and have started to do,
came about when I was in Texas.
I met a guy, his
name's Oscar Munoz.
Oscar is in charge of the
Texas A&M Colonias programs
all along the border.
Texas is a third the width
of the United States.
So that distance, and
then 150 miles up,
is called the border of Texas.
In that space, there
live over a half
a million people, most
of whom don't have access
to clean water in their homes.
And Oscar let me know this,
and he works with communities
all across that swath.
And as an art educator,
that was interesting to me.
Because I had to learn
about a lot of the practices
that he's up against, and faces.
I'm telling you
all this to say--
not that I planned
where my work has gone,
but it's always migrated--
always moved and shifted--
to new-- it's almost like water,
water finds its own level,
right?
Water fills the vessel
in which it's poured.
But I've never lost the clay.
I've never lost that
notion of making.
Or the ways that meanings can
be made, and understandings
can be constructed through
engagement with other people.
That's what education
is, it's a social space.
Teaching and learning
is a social space.
Art education can take up and
take on those tasks as well.
LARRY SUSSKIND: The
title for this visit
that people have seen,
and that you gave us,
is Making Something
from Nothing.
And first of all, the
immediate doubt about
whether you can actually make--
I mean, you can
transform things--
but the notion that you can
make something out of nothing
would sort of defy most of the
laws of physics, presumably.
And so, you mean
something by that.
And then, Appropriate Technology
as Intentionally Disruptive
Responsibility.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: That is a
mouthful, that title, isn't it?
LARRY SUSSKIND: I actually
had a lot of trouble with it.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: To the left
of the colon, making something
from nothing.
That piece was intentionally
provocative, right?
I mean, you kind of have
to do that, in some ways,
to entice folks to show up
to certain things, maybe.
But the idea of making--
of course, defying laws of
physics, yeah, I'm with you.
So knowing that there's
a problem with that,
if we think of it
in certain realms,
the idea that there's some
folks who don't necessarily have
access-- it's about access.
Maybe it should have said,
making something from whatever
it is that you have.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Right.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Right?
But if we move it
to nothing, you
start to think, well, there's
a complete and utter lack
of something.
For example, there's
some people who
have no access to clean water.
We can raise a bit
of hyperbole there
and say they don't have
access, or they have nothing.
They're folks who-- we
talk about food scarcity,
we talk about folks who
are homeless folks, who
need shelter.
So you can take minimum,
and exaggerate it
just a little bit more--
there's this thing
called artistic license,
let's use that--
and turn it into nothing.
So making something
from nothing,
what can we make from
what is available to us?
So that's the
something from nothing.
And in the case of
this first visit,
the something is adequate
access to clean water.
And the nothing is
the lack of that.
And the something is a
response, which in this case,
is a ceramic water filter
made out of clay and sawdust.
The nothing is, well,
that's just clay.
It's just in the riverbed.
That's nothing.
That's just sawdust,
that's leftover scraps.
That's nothing.
You understand that
play that's going there?
Appropriate technology
is essentially
whatever is
available culturally,
and locally, that fits in
within the cultural practices
of a community.
Introducing an external,
or an unfamiliar substance,
or chemical, or food,
is not appropriate
to a certain community.
Because it's either
against one's religion,
it's against one's history,
against one's culture.
It doesn't fit in, so finding
something that's appropriate.
For example, clay is
essentially a material
that is accessible to
almost every single culture
in the history of the world.
And clay is a naturally
occurring material
in most places around the world.
Now, some places
using plastic, that
doesn't seem to make sense.
Or appropriate technologies,
using what is at hand.
Philosopher, theorist
Umberto Eco--
he was a guy who
knew everything,
but he didn't know it.
Eco had numerous theories.
Among them was this
theory of intentions.
When he says the artist, or
the author, has an intention,
and the viewer, or the
reader, has an intention.
But he also says the
work has an intention.
That comes about through this
process, or a series of events.
But this idea of
having an intention
means it's deliberate.
So I'm interested in
thinking about why
we're doing what we're doing.
That's where that
intentional piece--
disruptive.
If I pick this up, and I threw
this water at the camera,
that would be disruptive
in a number of ways.
Or if you're in a quiet library,
and a stampede of aardvarks
comes through the space,
that's disruption.
So we understand disruption
as something that is abnormal,
or not expected within
a particular context
that has assumed rules,
regulations, and ways of being.
But I'm also thinking
of disruption
in the intentional sense of,
to reveal, or to poke at,
or to engage, or to entice a
certain kind of conversation,
or relationship.
And that conversation
or relationship
is the responsibility.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Would you agree
that most educational efforts
are disruptions aimed at
fulfilling a responsibility,
that it's defining
education that way?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: I don't
think enough of them are.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Oh, you
think they should be.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
I think they should.
I'd like to shift that
up, and question that.
And it's very difficult to get
at new ways of doing something,
without disrupting a status
quo, without questioning it.
LARRY SUSSKIND: We say it's
because we're responsible
and we have to disrupt,
but what about the choice
of the people, and the place,
whose lives you're disrupting?
Is that fair to them?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Sure.
Yeah.
Certainly the way you frame
it, it's not fair to them.
But in the disruption
of the lives
of communities that I
mentioned, in Texas,
is not disrupting uninvited.
It's an invited disruption.
And second, the
disruption has to do
with whatever the current
practice was, was not
fulfilling, or responding
to needs of the community.
LARRY SUSSKIND: In their eyes.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
In their eyes.
And to my eyes, as well.
So my friend-- as I mentioned--
Oscar, who for years has been
working throughout South Texas.
When he learned of the
work I that I was--
at that point-- still
learning how to do,
he said, oh, there's
a water issue.
Would you come down, and
work with us, talk to us,
let's see if this
would work out.
That was my
invitation to come in.
Oscar was already part
of that community,
I would never imagine
just driving down there--
driving to any community--
and say, hey, I have
something you need.
I'm going to sell you something.
That's not my approach.
And so, that kind of
disruption, I think,
is on the unethical side.
He was a bit wary of
someone coming in.
And he's shared--
and other people
have shared-- stories
with me of researchers
going into communities, oh,
yeah, I have these ideas.
Let me study what you're doing.
Let me work with you.
And they take the
information, and there's
a report that's promised,
and the report never
gets back to the communities.
Or the results never help.
And he said he had never
seen a report come back,
based on the invitations
to the scholars.
And so, once we got
to know each other,
he felt comfortable with me.
But then he had to go through a
process of talking with members
of the community and
say, hey, here's--
I have this friend coming down.
That's the invitation piece.
LARRY SUSSKIND: So what does
an invitation have to consist
of-- for you--
to be of a sort that you are
comfortable then responding
in this disruptive way?
Do you need a vote
or the community?
Has to be 100 percent?
Majority rule?
People you like
say, come on down?
What is, in your
mind, what legitimizes
these kinds of disruptions?
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Again, there has
to be that invitation from
someone who is positioned
within the community.
Then there has to be--
for me-- a conversation.
And so, no, the
entire community.
Because defining who
is in the community
is often difficult to do anyway.
Certainly, it's
often just a leader,
or a member of the
community who might
want engage a conversation,
that then might
expand in their own circles.
In this particular case--
in Texas, through
my colleague-- we
met with a few
leaders, people who
had worked within the
communities as [SPANISH],,
as community educators,
and other senior members
of the community.
Senior meaning they
had been doing work
at the community centers.
And it was, let's
just talk, let's
see where the conversation goes.
Very much like what we're doing
here, having a conversation.
Now, it's not my role or
position, or personality,
or interest, to push that.
After that conversation, that's
on whomever to take that up.
So when I speak of community,
it's not the entirety.
LARRY SUSSKIND: There's not
a simple answer to this.
We all struggle with
this notion of the artist
as a independent thinker,
as a creator of something
that's an expression of
an individual view when
you're calling this a
form of art education.
But isn't it contrary to
artists being artists?
How is it art?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: So
that's not a small question,
but it's a very
important question.
It's a central question that
I'm still answering for myself.
But there are three realms here.
One is the work in South Texas,
that I actually wouldn't call
that art, or art education.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Oh, OK.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: OK?
Second is the kind of work
that I will do tomorrow,
the performance.
And that moves into the
realm of social practice.
And that's where I've come to
an agreement, understanding,
comfortable place with
myself, that that's where
the art education happens.
And then, there's a third piece,
your definition of an artist,
and what an artist does,
that I want to disrupt.
Down in South Texas, that
kind of work, for me,
is not art education.
It certainly uses an employees
certain artistic practices.
Folks who have
access to a kiln--
know how to fire a
kiln-- and have access
to clay, that's where you
want to begin your work.
Usually that's the tile
person, or the potter,
or it's the brick maker.
But my collaboration, and my
involvement in that project, I
wouldn't call that art.
That was kind of me shed--
if that helps to clarify
that piece of it.
So the work that I
will do tomorrow.
I'm going to set up a
water filter production
facility in one of
the rooms downstairs,
and going to make water filters.
The idea there is to engage in
a practice that somehow blurs
what might be our conventional
notions of art making, art
practice, with practices
from other disciplines.
We're not quite sure where
one ends, and one begins.
And it's supposed to remain
in that uncomfortable space,
if one is thinking in that
social practice-- art is
social practice-- register.
If you can set up that
practice as an engagement,
as an ongoing set of
activities, where people
can come in and
out of that space,
there's an
educational component.
Invariably, there'll
be a question, hey man,
what are you doing?
That's an invitation, right
there, for me to respond.
So we can establish this
conversation as a relationship.
LARRY SUSSKIND: You're
not creating art.
You're creating something that
serves a function in response
to the need of a client.
You're saying, no it's not art.
I'm an artist, and
it's my social practice
that you should observe
here as art education.
But the product of my
artwork is not art.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: It's
more than the filter itself.
That filter is just one
component of the work.
The work being the performance.
Education as experience,
this notion of experience
is where the education happens.
LARRY SUSSKIND: For some of
us, the next step is, oh,
and I want to help
a place in Africa,
or Latin America,
in a community,
make a factory where
there are people--
now, without me there--
capable of making more filters.
And maybe they can sell
'em for a small amount
to be able to maintain
a community business.
The doing of all of that
seems to be a different realm.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: It is, yeah.
And I have not worked
closely with communities--
as you're saying--
to set up facilities.
Although, in South Texas, I did.
I helped laid the groundwork
in that facility--
LARRY SUSSKIND: I saw pictures.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: --is working.
You saw pictures, right.
But there are a
number of groups who
are doing the exact kind of
work that you're mentioning.
And it's not from an arts, or
an art education perspective.
It is from that social
entrepreneur realm
that you're talking about.
And I am very supportive
of that piece.
And that is actually
an intriguing component
of what comes out of this work.
It's that work that
then has benefits
in terms of health, economics,
self-sustaining capacity,
that I find intriguing.
And it's something
that can be attempted,
where it's not intended to
be a money maker initially,
it's intended to
save people's lives,
and to respond in that way.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious about the longer
term with this
community in South Texas
that you're working with.
Obviously, it sounds like
there's a really pressing need,
so these water filters can
meet that immediate need.
Is the long term goal still
to get a more traditional grid
water setup for them?
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yeah.
Yes.
The origin of the
filters was that they
were supposed to be a first
response to natural disaster,
and they were not
supposed to be long term.
Their point of use,
temporary solutions.
Unfortunately for some
folks around the world,
these have become more
long term responses.
AUDIENCE: What do you do when
you're just starting out?
What's your advice for how you
go about getting an invitation?
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
That's a tough one.
Sometimes it's not about poking
for the invitation initially.
Sometimes you find ways to
become part of the community.
At some level, that
might sound like, oh,
but you're really
kind of manipulating.
Because in the back of
your mind you're saying,
OK, at the right moment, I'm
going to spring the question.
I'm going to get the invitation.
That's not what
I'm talking about.
What I'm talking about is
being part of a community,
and doing the work
in the community.
Where the work that
you're doing might be seen
by folks who could invite you.
Again, that sounds like
it's some sort of nefarious,
manipulative component.
But not really, I think it's
about continuing your work,
and staying visible.
And the invitations come.
There's an approach called
arts entrepreneurship that
is gaining traction,
and several universities
have courses in arts
entrepreneurship-- and minors,
and I think a few are starting
majors as well, or have majors.
Because these other groups
are doing this kind of work,
folks know about the
water filter technology.
It's starting to take off,
and people are collaborating,
they're entering
into that space.
And what they're doing,
is they're making
available for their learners--
K-12 learners-- possibilities
that they might not
have thought.
It's the curriculum
work that I'm
doing with teachers, I think,
that becomes quite engaging.
LARRY SUSSKIND: Great.
Thank you all, very much.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Thank you very much.
Yeah, hope to see you tomorrow.
Thank you, thank you.